Jeremy Renner is in critical condition
following a snowplow incident over the
weekend a rep for the actor confirmed
the news in a statement Sunday
explaining Jeremy is in critical but
stable condition with injuries After
experiencing a weather-related accident
while plowing snow the rep adds Jeremy
is with his family and receiving
excellent care on Monday E.T learned
Jeremy underwent chest surgery to
address his injuries his publicist
revealed that he suffered blunt chest
trauma and Orthopedic injuries as a
result of the accident and remains in
critical but stable condition the washu
county sheriff's office tells E.T the
accident occurred in the Mount Rose
Highway area in Reno Sunday morning
Jeremy was the only involved party in
the incident and he was airlifted to a
local area Hospital following the news
Jeremy's Pals and collaborators shared
their well wishes James Gunn tweeted my
heart is with Jeremy Brenner Josh gadd
wrote my God praying for Jeremy Renner
and his family meanwhile Mark Ruffalo
asked fans to pray for his Avengers
co-star Riding on His insta story quote
prayers up for our brother Jeremy Renner
on a full and speedy recovery Jeremy who
lives outside of Reno near Mount Rose
Ski Tahoe shared lots of footage with
his snowplow on social media
Jeremy captioned that clip from December
clearing a path with his plow quote I
have so much respect for Mother Earth
and mother nature I expect to lose the
fight but I'll always give it my best
shot and in another post from November
Jeremy gave fans a look at how he gears
up for the season riding Monday morning
pre-winter preparation couldn't be more
fun hashtag Reno hashtag Tahoe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]